alors sophie ça ici alors ta première
boîtier ici je vais soulever et tu vas
devoir me dire quel objet tu est en
train de tripoter tu mettras t'es d'min
des deux côtés comme ça d'accord
attention j'ai le droit d'y relais ou
pas oui tu as le droit de tout faire
merci attention c'est parti
vas-y vas-y non non non non non non
t'inquiète t'inquiète sauf inquiète a
dit pas ce débat mais si jamais c'est
des animaux dès lors ne t'inquiète pas
vas-y tu peux tu peux du pbc baisse
bastia metz les mains basses tes mains
mais est ce encore baisse encore laisse
encore c'est jean-michel merde non non
non c'est quoi qu'est-ce que c'est un
truc qui me manque c'est quoi ton ami et
une araignée une mygale une mygale
télécommande et ça vous inquiétez pas sa
télécommande et sait rien de la saison
attention deuxième objet c'est parti
sophie s'est pas dissocié combat dix ans
et plus ne t'inquiète pas tu en as oui
sachant que konami a déjà
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ce que tu penses c'est
jean-michel attention troisième objet
sophie attention c'est show sa répartie
mais calme je ne sais quoi vivent ces
familles donc ça dépend el essawy
brasier qui chauffe essaie de trouver
asile va tirer du tout goûté à la pâte
d'angers 0 danser c'est quoi j'étais
déçu moi tu peux toucher à ça une tête
c'est que c'est quoi net salesches
saleix ce qui bat gens sachent c'est
quelqu'un de consommateurs au tour à
tour d'un bug on peut les battre le
retour à son fils yoplait le retour
assez pierre-jean
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi